you know many of the challenges we face
whether it's standing up to Russian
aggression here in Moldova or in Ukraine
but also tackling illegal migration are
challenges that we can only really solve
when we work together with other
countries I've been having a series of
very productive discussions here to
strengthen everyone's support for
Ukraine but also to work cooperatively
to tackle illegal migration which is one
of my five big priorities
one of the meetings you had prime
minister was with the president of
Ukraine is a landscape and of course
yesterday we also heard from the French
President saying that he would like a
clear plan on Ukraine joining NATO
presented next month already do you
agree with this timeline and did you
give some sort of reassurances to
present zielinski in terms of when
Ukraine might be able to join NATO well
I agree with the NATO Secretary General
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO and
what we're also talking to Ukraine about
right now is making sure that they have
all the support they need for a
successful counter-offensive one of the
things we've recently done in the UK is
provide longer range weapons to Ukraine
we were also the first country to
provide main battle tanks I'm proud of
that record and we want to make sure
that we put in place security
arrangements for Ukraine for the long
term so that we send a very strong
signal to valade me Putin that we're not
going anywhere we are here to stay and
we'll continue backing Ukraine not just
now but for years into the future and he
needs to know that and we will send that
signal of support
prime minister you've said that your
government will have integrity
professionalism and accountability at
every level
does that mean that you're going to
follow the deadline of 4 pm lending time
today to comply and send and redacted
messages to the covet inquiry that's
taking place well I think it's really
important that we learn the lessons of
covid so that we can be better prepared
in the future and we're doing that in a
spirit of rigor but also transparency
and Candor we've cooperated the
government's cooperated thoroughly with
the inquiry today handing over tens of
thousands of of documents and we will
continue to comply of course with the
law and cooperate with the inquiry we're
confident in our position but are
carefully considering next steps and
just to level check would you be willing
to take this subject to court as I said
we've been long cooperating with the
inquiry important that we learn the
lessons of covid so that we're well
prepared in the future governments
considering very carefully next steps
but it's confident in its position